[inaudible]
joining me today are two of the guys who pulled off the biggest socal hoke
since,
well,
the original Soko hoax.
Peter goes in and James Lindsay,
welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks for having a solid.
I am happy to have you guys here.
You're an old pro around here.
It's good to be back.
Yeah.
Pleasure.
You're a first time I read enough.
I'm all new.
Well then with that spirit,
I'm going to ask you the first question for people who have no idea what the
original socal hoax is,
because we're obviously going to spend a lot of time talking about what you guys
have done in the last year.
What was the original socal hooks when people say,
oh,
they did a socal hoax.
What is that?
So Alan socal was a physicist,
or is a physicist at Nyu and he in the nineties 95 [inaudible] 96 he was looking
at this postmodern cultural criticism and he was reading what they're doing and
they're using math words or using physics ideas and terms and they're just
making up stuff,
you know,
like the,
some theorem about any,
some theorem about equality or inequalities and mathematics.
And they'll say,
oh,
well,
there's obviously means that there's inequalities and you know,
run with the pun on inequality and say some social stuff about it.
And he started reading some of the stuff that they republican or you thought,
there's no way,
not only are they abusing science,
there's no way that even understand what they're saying.
And he wanted to check that out.
So he wrote this paper,
transgressing the boundaries toward something.
What is it?
A hermeneutics truly transformative hermeneutic of quantum gravity.
That sounds very impressive.
It's to put it more simply wanted to argue that quantum gravity as a social
construct of course.
And so he did this thing and he wrote this complete nonsense paper,
what they call a Pastiche,
where he just took quotes from the famous postmodernists and filled in with
nonsense and use lots of mathematical and physical,
you know,
scientific words and misuse them to say goofy things.
And he sent it to a preeminent,
a social commentary postponed or social commentary journal at Duke University
Social Tech called social text.
And uh,
their editors accepted it and published it.
Um,
and then the same day they published it,
he came out and said,
ah,
you know,
this was a fake,
he published an x was a article about it and said,
this is why I did.
It.
Ended up writing a bestselling New York Times best selling book called
fashionable nonsense,
talking about all these guys use these fashionable terms and just say the right
political things and it's all nonsense.
It doesn't really mean anything.
And so that was sort of the state of,
you know,
what was going on and postmodern cultural theory in the 1990s and he struck a
big blow against it.
Big Controversy,
New York Times,
front page story all over the world.
People dumping on him and some people supporting him,
some people dumping on him.
He was,
he was a big mess.
Yeah.
So that was the original hoax.
And he was trying to show that,
you know,
they were abusing scientific terminology,
taking out of the scientific context and using it to make political points for,
of course,
academic leftist,
kind of a fashionable points of view.
Right?
So this is a great precursor to everything that you guys have done,
right?
It's so consistent with the conversations that we've been having for years.
And so many of the conversations I'm having on the show,
this,
this postmodern leftist orthodoxy,
it's actually nonsense.
And,
and,
and you guys set out to prove it was nonsense.
We did the first time we wrote a paper that conceptual penis as a social
construct and we argue that among other things,
penises are responsible for climate change.
And that,
that paper,
now that's true,
but the rest of the paper was completely relevant.
It came under considerable,
uh,
criticism.
And so we took a look at that criticism and we said,
okay,
let's see if we can replicate this on a grand scale.
So to be clear,
that was the first one that you did where you were trying to yeah,
I did that one.
Yeah.
But that,
that was the first one that you guys did,
that you were trying to get through this system.
The Gates are disbursed to show that they couldn't distinguish between made up
silliness and their own scholarship.
And then we,
we took a look at that criticism and we decided to replicate that on a massive
scale.
Yeah.
So we wrote 20 papers in 10 months.
And for context,
these are papers that go to peer review journals,
seven papers in seven years.
His tenure at most major universities.
And we wrote with the help of Helen Pluck rose from reo magazine who is in the
UK,
is not here now obviously,
uh,
we,
we had seven of those published or accepted for publication and the Wall Street
Journal caught us.
We had seven more under review or we were going to resubmit.
Okay.
So let's pause there for a second.
Tell me,
let's just go through some of the greatest hits of these papers that you got
through.
I mean they're,
they're quite brilliant,
but are there any that you each like to tee off?
Oh my gosh,
all of them.
Yes.
Yeah.
So the,
the,
the most famous of the papers as far as people having heard about it was one
that Peter wrote the first draft of and that was the,
the dog humping paper as well referred to it.
Um,
it was the paper,
what was it called?
Um,
the title where performance in Rape Culture and Portland dog park or something
like that,
uh,
that you can't quite remember.
The name sort of shows you the absurdity of what you've done.
Like they all have like the serious subtitle and some of them have easy to
remember.
Funny Real Title Park is what we,
we all,
we gave him all nicknames are code names or whatever throughout.
So the really the nitty gritty part,
like a human performativity in human reactions to Queer performativity in rape
culture and urban dog parks or whatever.
That's all.
It's all just kind of scholarly mishmash.
It's hard to keep up with,
but that paper is sort of be greatest hit because not only was it accepted for
publication,
not only was it published,
but the journal deemed that it was one of the best papers in feminist geography
and gave it a special recognition was gonna make a big deal of,
it should lay out a little more specifically what it is that you were saying
because it was such an important academic original point of that paper was to
argue that rape culture is a big problem and the best way that we could
intervene upon that would be to train men the way we train dogs.
And so that was the original concept and the idea was we're going to start with
our conclusion and try to get there.
How do we get to train men?
Like we train dogs.
And so I told Pete because he takes his dogs to the dog park every day.
I said,
Pete,
use your experience from the dog park.
Maybe we get a dog training manual and try to figure it out from there.
And so he goes off the dog training manual thing.
Just wasn't working.
So he just starts writing his experience.
His experience in absurd made up experience at the dog park about he sits at the
dog park four or five hours a day,
but never in heavy rain and observes dogs and they're,
they're humping behavior and their fight closely observed the genitals of close
to $10,000.
Yeah,
inspected genitals.
I am committed,
I,
unless it's raining and then in turn Reigate their owners as their sexual
orientation.
But we needed something else in there,
you know,
like choice slides,
dog parks are petri dishes for Canine rape cultures.
But we need something else.
And again,
the trick to this thing is what's morally fashionable?
Who is the most depression variables?
So I thought,
well,
you know,
a black female criminologists so I like googled black female criminology.
I just looked at Wikipedia and it was like I found someone,
I'm like,
okay,
let's look at this through a lens of black female criminology.
They can't reject it because they'd be saying that there's something wrong
there.
There'd be not validating someone's lived experience.
So we looked at the whole thing through black feminist criminology bulletin
published.
So we've got seven of those and are accepted with seven more than mine come
three right.
Wait,
let's not gloss over that one cause this is actually incredible what you did.
Okay.
Well you want to go through the levels by far the most difficult of the papers
so you can incredible I guess is fair because it was really hard.
We had like proper internal meltdowns trying to figure out how to make this
work.
Um,
we took a chapter of mine comp,
uh,
Hitler's auto ethnography as a manifesto.
It's an auto ethnography for the first half.
And so we were flipping through a trial.
We thought the original thought behind that really was,
I think Helen suggested that we should take some awful old thing.
It wasn't specified that there'd be my comp yet,
like a theologian just railing on something or whatever,
some famous old tracks that's just gross and then rewrite it as postmodern,
a activist,
progressive activism or whatever.
And so it naturally led very quickly to mind comp.
That's,
that's the example.
So I'm reading through mine comp and then chapter 11 is the big home run
chapter.
It's like that's,
I think the,
you know,
something railing on the Jews shows up 400 times in chapter 11 alone.
And it was like,
Whoa,
that's too extreme.
Can't actually use that.
Flip to chapter 12
this is where Hitler makes us call for.
How are we going to organize the Nazi party and what sacrifices are necessary?
And I'm reading through this,
I'm thinking,
oh my gosh,
this is it.
So I copy and pasted that straight out of off the internet onto a word document.
And I went through and everywhere it said,
our movement,
the party,
whatever,
took that out,
stuck in intersectional feminism.
And then I started making the sentences make sense around that.
And then we went through and changed all the wording just a little so it get
past plagiarism and that gave us this kind of unreadable document that was just
as transliteration of of Hitler's chapter 12 about how to be Nazis.
And then I think it's incredible.
Then we just added in theory.
Yeah.
So Helen went through primarily and was like,
Oh wow,
this reminds me,
she was reading a lot about choice feminism,
which is that if a woman makes her own choices,
that's feminist,
which seems like a pretty reasonable approach to feminism if you want to go with
one.
And so Helen was looking at how they were criticizing choice feminism and
thought that might be a good way to go with this.
So she's like,
wow,
this looks like this,
this one paper,
this looks like another one.
This will fit here.
And then I went through some of the intersectional,
uh,
you know,
critical race feminism scholarship,
the black feminism scholarship.
I was like,
Oh wow,
this sounds like that,
this sounds like that.
And we just started weaving in theory in between pieces of Hitler while we tried
to maintain the tone and flavor that Hitler was putting out.
So Hillary lays out of 14 point plan to design the Nazi party and we condensed
it down to eight,
reordered them so that they kind of made sense in some kind of a theoretical
structure.
And we sent it off to feminist theory,
a journal,
and we thought there's no way.
You know,
we just wanted to see what would happen.
We had no thinking that this would possibly get in and feminist theory,
pure reviewed it.
They rejected it,
but they peer reviewed it and then all of a sudden that was right when we went
to Portland in February last year and it was like this is a big deal that they
took it to peer review because we're going to get comments.
So the goal of that paper became get reviewer comments on the section of mine
competency.
When they say about it,
when they review it,
still assuming they reject it.
We took those comments to feminist theory gave us saying,
oh,
it's too liberal.
You're trying to universalize feminism and that means one woman can speak for
another woman.
It's too liberal.
That's actually,
yeah,
that's my business,
isn't it?
It's so,
so then we took those,
those comments.
We modified it a little bit.
We massage it to fit for a social work journal by working in social work stuff.
We send it off to a feminist social work journal and the Feminist Social Work
Journal gave us a few more comments.
You need to make problem,
you need to do,
make allyship problematic because if I claim I'm an ally now I have a power
dynamic with the person I'm allied with.
So problem with that slave that would be better.
Yeah.
Something.
And so we did that and we sent it in back to them and they accepted it and it
was like probably days away from actually being published when Wall Street
Journal broke their story.
But they accepted this rewritten chapter of mine comp that stayed true.
And the key to that,
what really happened with that is that Hitler was pushing the politics of Hitler
grew to power because he was pushing politics of grievance.
Germany got screwed.
We are going to rise back up to a great Germany,
blah,
Blah Blah Grievance,
grievance,
what we called our stuff that we were targeting grievance studies because they
study social grievances through not German identity,
your national identity,
but through a personal identity,
race,
gender,
sexuality and so on.
And so the politics of Grievance,
we're very appealing in a feminist social work journal.
That grievance can go into social work and been informed social workers on how
to make feminism more solidified to improve social work outcomes.
And that's where it gets really scary.
Right?
Cause that's a practical field.
Right.
So,
okay.
So before we go too far on that,
let's just back up for one second and what sort of led you to and Helen to
decide to do this in the first place.
So my audience is pretty familiar with you,
but maybe you want to give a little bit of why,
why you,
why did,
why is it that you said,
this is what we have to do to,
to sort of strike this thing at the knees.
So they,
people had recognized what the problem was.
The problem being postmodernism,
the problem being a corrupt corruption in scholarship.
The problem being that many disciplines have lost a focus on truth.
They thought they already had the truth.
So they placed an agenda before the truth.
Uh,
and we're deeply concerned about speech issues on campus.
We're deeply concerned about what the fact that kids in class couldn't view
alternative opinions.
And I myself don't hold those opinions.
I'm not a conservative,
I'm not Christian obviously,
but I wanted,
I want people to have the opportunity to voice their ideas and then other people
to have the opportunity to respond to those ideas.
And so we took a look at this and we traced it back to a single body of
scholarship,
basically anything that has the name studies behind it.
And so what had happened is that these people have,
these folks have taken over the educational administration and they're
institutionalizing ideas found in this body of literature and it's absolutely
toxic to us.
It's poisoning us all.
And we wanted to take a look at those canons of literature,
which is actually when I called you.
Yeah,
yeah.
You called me that day and you were like,
am I crazy?
Am I going crazy?
And I was like,
probably carry on Pete.
And so continued.
Yeah,
please go on.
And so he said,
he said,
you know,
I've been looking at to,
to give a little more context,
actually we were,
before I get to that we were in,
we were in looking at social media and a lot of the people that are trying to
have mostly on the left or try,
you know,
centrist liberals are trying to have honest conversations about issues about
race,
sexuality and so on.
And what happens?
Boom,
racist,
sexist,
Sam Harris blasted for being a sexist over some comments you made.
I know a little bit about this a little bit.
Do you?
Uh,
and getting blasted for being a racist because of the Islamophobia thing and the
grows on racist moment with Ben Affleck,
you know,
the,
all this stuff was going on.
We're like,
what's going on?
And you try to have conversations,
you know,
with like Sam Harris is a reasonable guy.
He's an honest broker.
What's happening?
And we start getting called racist for talking about it.
And then every time it comes back to this,
we'll,
racism doesn't mean what the dictionary says.
Racism doesn't mean what you think it means.
Only white people can be racist,
only men can be sexist and it has to have structural power behind it and all of
this stuff.
And we're like,
that's a peculiar definition and maybe,
okay system systemic racism is a thing.
It's real.
Okay fine.
But that's not the whole story here.
You know,
you're using a particular term,
you're,
you're meaning a particular term by a very general term racism.
Systemic racism is real.
What do you mean?
What I'm meaning is the,
certainly there,
there are structural forces that we have for decades or centuries possibly at
least in the United States,
disenfranchise certain individuals.
We,
we,
there was going way back,
we have slavery,
we come out of slavery and then there was segregation and there were Jim crow
laws and we come out of that and there was,
you know,
systematically screwing over,
the housing markets in certain cities.
Chicago was particularly bad for that.
So there's this kind of ghettoization of it and there's all kinds of stuff like
that.
Heather have created a,
I think that the scholars are correct to say that there's something of an
unlevel playing field going on.
There've been great improvements.
However,
there are still some issues.
There are still some,
some concerns there.
You know,
they do these studies where they put out things and they put a white sounding
name or a black sounding name and then that doesn't come out clean.
Those,
there's a bias there.
Right.
So this just for the record,
I mean this is where I would,
where I've gotten into that moment with Larry elder that you mentioned before.
I don't know.
I personally wouldn't call that systemic anymore.
I don't think it's in the system anymore.
That may be individual dipole act in a racist way or in a sexist way or
something like that.
But that doesn't mean there isn't historical
and it,
so everybody got it.
I don't think that there is a institutional thing,
whether it comes down,
I don't know whether there are issues,
say within the police or whatever that may be.
There are lots of racist cops and maybe there aren't,
I don't know.
But whether it's codify it or not,
I don't think that that problem where it's not codafide anymore.
I just think it was coded by that distinction.
Yeah,
and the historical hangovers and et cetera.
There's a lot to it,
but sure,
I can accept the idea like let's just run with the idea that this whole
structural racism thing is a thing.
Well,
when you say racism,
but you mean structural racism,
you're cheating.
You're,
you're saying one word that means something to almost everybody,
but you mean something really narrow and specific by him.
We see this was,
you know,
racism.
We saw it with sexism.
See it with diversity.
You see it with inclusion.
You see it with equity.
You see word after word after word,
and this is how we traced back to the literature.
It's like where are these kind of odd ball definitions coming from?
Oh,
and s at the time we thought sociology and so this is where Pete calls me one
day we started looking at this literature and he calls me,
he's like,
am I crazy?
Am I losing it?
I look at this scholarship and I was just talking to somebody about it and they
didn't get it.
So help me out here.
I look at this scholarship and it,
it's like this gender studies scholarship plays the exact same role for gender
scholars that the Bible Place for Christians at the Quran plays for for Muslims.
Is that what's going on here?
And I would,
I had just written this book or was in the process,
I don't remember exactly the date.
I had written this book trying to look at the psychological motivations behind
belief in God and what people mean by that.
And I was like,
actually I think you are exactly on it.
You know,
because the idea of God represents things like morality and purpose and
community and various things to different people.
And here you have,
they all religions,
all have scriptures are nearly all have scriptures.
I think you actually do have the same thing here.
You have this special revelation going on where people are able to put down
their opinions and somehow it gets legitimized through a moral process in
religion.
It's,
you know,
a holiness,
you're holy enough.
You put down your opinion,
your Augustan,
you put down your confessions and now it becomes sacred writ.
And in this case it's through this kind of weakness in the,
in the progressive moral architecture that allows for people never want to be
even not just do they not want to be racist,
they want to be considered racist,
they want to be accidentally secret,
considered racist.
They want to be complicit and racism.
And there's in this whole thing to where this is such a huge taboo,
they're so afraid to become racist that they've let this stuff past to where
people can write theoretical prejudices and opinions in as if they are
scholarship.
And then it gets validated and published in the peer reviewed literature.
Now there's a study that says,
right,
whatever it is
to that point,
to this study.
And they say,
so that's,
they don't need faith.
They,
they point to this,
this is how we know in your for guests and our friend Brett Orange team calls it
idea laundering.
They have an idea,
they have a moral impulse.
They want to discharge that.
They write in their,
Jay may have these make believe journals and they publish it and then they start
teaching it to folks.
And then that's how it spreads.
It's like a contagion.
Yeah.
Right.
We couldn't have the conversation right,
because that's what they would do because you try to have a conversation and
they say this thing and you say,
well how do you know that?
And they're like this.
And they point to the scholarship and Pete's idea was that's the same as when a,
when a Christian is,
you know,
ranting about fire and brimstone and you're like,
how do you know that this,
and they point to Deuteronomy or whatever,
you know,
and it's the same concept.
And so then you can't,
what do you do?
How do you argue?
Well,
the only thing you can do is say,
well maybe that scholarships questionable.
And then that conversation wasn't possible because if you question the
scholarship,
you're racist.
So we said,
well,
let's look at the scholarship.
Yeah.
So you were piecing this together for a long time because I quote you every
other week on the show.
When you started calling this postmodern movement,
a secular,
religious,
secular religion.
We've been talking about that for years and then all of a sudden all all you
know I,
Andrew Sullivan,
I serve mcwhorter.
I saw all these people talking about it.
I'm I saying,
you know,
we're first or anything,
the hipsters have the secretary.
Well you are the first person that I heard talk about it and that guy was so
obvious because we came from this,
from the new atheist and the parallels with striking.
And just on that,
I think Mike Neda has a video on that,
that we tweeted a in which you can see,
you can literally see the canoe story that happened to Britain,
Heather.
And it's uh,
what's it Mike Natives?
Youtube
channel is youtube
wells are there.
They're not just conspicuous there.
You can't ignore them.
Yeah.
It's impossible to watch this little documentary he's done on evergreen just
recently.
So for your viewers that don't know,
Mike,
Nina is actually a documentary filmmaker who came in.
He was looking at the same kinds of problems going on in Australia,
getting curious about it.
That ended up by chance leading to us crossing paths.
We told them about what we were doing last fall 2017 and he was like,
okay,
I'll document it as long as I'm allowed to tell the truth about everything.
And we're like,
yeah,
that's what we want to do.
Anyway.
So we have a documentary filmmaker,
there's been following us around tracking what we've been doing and because the
problems so complicated,
he slowly,
you know,
the Helen and Peter and I get all this,
like we did this project and we wrote these papers.
We've actually kind of had the secret secret fourth member who is this filmmaker
who is,
he learned more and more about it became kind of an integral contributor to our
thinking and our ideas and how to communicate it.
And so he's now working on a documentary,
a feature length documentary about us and the work we did.
But he also was running a youtube channel with shorts about either us,
what we're doing and he just released this,
um,
hour,
almost hour long documentary,
first half of a,
of a longer piece on evergreen.
That's like Netflix quality.
I mean it's for real.
You get,
you really do want to check it out on his youtube channel and it is impossible.
I would say to watch that and not see,
holy crap,
this is a religion and this is how it operates and this isn't just a religion.
This is a hardcore one.
No,
sorry,
go ahead.
Well,
so as the guy who wrote a manual for creating atheists deprogramming religious
thinking is something you've been interested in a long time.
So did you view this as the first blow to enable that process to start
happening?
I do.
I,
I think that they're,
their cannons,
their way,
they come to knowledge,
the method that they rely on is at the very least a reasonable person or barring
Walter Kauffman definition,
every reasonable person would have to look at that and say,
wait a second.
They have generated these self contained ecosystems that anyone looking at it
from the outside would realize.
But I do think that that one of the things this project showed was that those
canons are now de-legitimized.
There's no reason a serious person would take a look at that and say,
you know,
cause you had asked before your initial question,
like what are the papers?
What are the journals?
Uh,
you know,
we've published a piece in Hypatia in,
in which that piece said there was the joke's on you and it was criticizing us
for the conceptual penis,
but it was very meta paper because of the joke was actually on them for
publishing the paper.
Right?
So I think that a reasonable person who would look at this would say,
wow,
there's something going on here.
But look at the reaction to this.
It's interesting.
You know,
it's like,
yes,
I wrote a manual for creating atheists and what's the next,
what would,
what would a reasonable person say,
a reasonable person say,
well,
I know that sexism is wrong.
I know that racism is wrong.
I know that these forms of discrimination are wrong and we want to study them.
Right?
And these folks pointed out at a very serious flooding in the literature and I
want to maintain my intellectual and scholarly integrity and we're going to try
to fix those problems.
The last,
but they have not done it.
They have done instead is exactly what he predicted.
And W we wrote about in the area of piece,
which was instead of taking a look at how they produce knowledge,
they,
they now scrutinize the authors who submit.
So they Google.
So they make sure that the authors are legit.
So instead of being a sincere inquirer,
again,
they think they already have truth.
Exactly like a fundamentalist.
Well,
so we've seen so many examples of this.
I mean,
I would say this is where they could have taken a look in the mirror after Trump
got elected.
They could have taken a look in the mirror after saying you can,
everyone's a Nazi and then you can punch Nazis and the list goes on and on of
when there could have been a moment of reflection.
We've never seen it.
So I know when we spoke a few days before the the Wall Street Journal piece went
home and we were talking about,
well,
maybe there's a chance this awake,
some of them up.
And I said to you,
I was like,
no,
of course not.
I mean,
there's,
there's nothing that that can be done.
So then in the face of that,
if you agree with the premise,
then what can be done other than we can,
you can keep doing this and we can keep talking about it.
We can keep waking other people up.
But for the people that are in that cult,
which I actually think is inappropriate idea for it,
and then what do you do?
Um,
you have to do what you always have to do,
which is you have to find ways in,
which means you have to find legitimate ways and effective ways and not a
authoritarian ways to,
um,
curtail their influence.
If they are unwilling to wake up or change their mind or reconsider,
then that's fine.
Within a liberal society,
everybody's allowed to follow their conscience are allowed to have.
That's the principle of freedom of religion.
Because you're allowed to worship as you will.
So if you want to worship the woke God of social justice,
whatever,
I know,
I suspect that they would not afford that freedom if they were really in charge.
You know,
those of us that may be don't believe in it
or you don't see it from hardcore religionists either they would,
they wouldn't afford the freedom if they got the power,
either theologians or theocrats or just as scary.
So if you want to,
if you want to curtail their power,
the answer is always in secularism.
And it does have to come from other people.
So within,
there are different audiences here,
right?
So there's everyday people they should,
they,
you know,
really think twice before they enroll at,
if it's a kid going to college before they enroll in a gender studies program,
uh,
yeah,
probably should somebody be stepping up in the advisory sector of the academy
and saying,
you know,
I think you have a lot of talents.
Say it's a young black student in a lot of talent.
You could go to graduate school,
you could study.
And instead of saying there's this opportunity for you to study this niche thing
about lived black experience in writing an auto ethnography and get your
guaranteed phd,
cause nobody's allowed to say you're wrong.
Maybe you could go into some field that it doesn't have to be,
you know,
everybody always goes to stem,
maybe it's engineering or whatever.
It doesn't have to be that.
It could be anything via historian,
be an economist,
be a political scientist to go in and study something more rigorous that
enhances your critical thinking in your dialectic process.
So that'd be advisors could do that.
And administrators.
So what is the flaw is the flow of that,
although I think you're right at some level as the floor there,
that because they are viewing this as a religion,
there's almost no way to show them that the people before them had any knowledge
of how the world works.
Like they really want to erase everything about the past.
Yeah.
I think ultimately there's the battleground is to get people to realize that
that's unacceptable.
So a good metaphor for that is I don't want to alienate any of your,
your hardest Tricia [inaudible] if you've ever been driving,
I know this is a dated example now with like cool,
futuristic radio and podcasts and things,
but you drive in and you're on a road trip,
you're in a difference,
you know,
region,
your dazzle and the dial on the radio and you're like,
God,
I can't find anything good to listen to.
And you flip thing as like country and you flipped the thing and it's something
else.
It's talk,
you don't want to listen to that.
You flipped the thing.
Ah,
some rock song comes on.
You're kind of like getting into it,
your role and you know,
hit the accelerator a little bit and then they're like,
Jesus is my light.
And you're like,
I know what this is.
You change the dial again right away because you hear that and you didn't want
to get proselytized to,
you wanted to listen to,
you know,
some,
some Metallica or something.
So you didn't want to hear that.
You thought you're into something and it's the wrong thing.
And so that,
that feeling you get though,
when you hear the religious thing that you didn't know was religious and it just
hooked you all of a sudden into religion,
that's the reaction that people should have.
They hear this woke stuff,
check your privilege.
I know what this is.
I'm not going along with that.
And if they want to point to something,
they want to point to some hard evidence.
These guys,
but Goshen,
Lindsey Pollak,
rose,
they did this thing and maybe we didn't,
I mean Pete says,
I like to nuance a little further than Pete did about de-legitimizing their
canon.
I think that there's probably some legitimate work going on,
but who can tell what it is?
How do you know if I can make up stuff and Pete can make up stuff and Helen can
make up stuff and we can just massage the literature to let it be.
How do you know when it's the real thing and when it's not.
So what we need is to clean that up and get,
get to the bottom of,
of when the work is using good,
rigorous methods and when it's not in review,
all this stuff.
Um,
so,
so I know you guys obviously got support out of the quarters that I would have
expected you to get support.
So Jordan Peterson and Jonathan Haidt and Steven pinker and debt and all these
guys.
Okay.
Uh,
that's not to be surprised because these guys have been talking about these
things.
Did you get any,
did you get any support though out of,
did you get anything out of say,
more lefty professors that you didn't really think we're gonna whisper in
whispers?
Yeah.
And this is again,
that consistent story with all of this.
So I find when I get emails from that type of person that says,
oh,
Dave,
you know,
you're,
you're doing the right thing here and you're calling out the nonsense of the
left.
And I just can't do it because I'm at a university or I have a job.
I actually am starting to hate those people.
I mean that sort of slightly sarcastic,
but it's not the right word,
but I'm really,
I'm really,
I've had it with those people.
I'm not a superhero.
I'm just doing what I think is right.
What is your feeling about that set of people at the university?
I think that we need to be more,
I don't mean this to sound in any other way,
but we need to be more compassionate for them.
Some people,
they don't have the,
they're just cowards and it's not their fault.
They're just live in a state of timidity or fear and they don't want to lose
their job.
Or maybe they prioritize employment in their families and whatever it is over
the truth that that's the life they lead.
Yeah.
If you're in a system where the system itself does not take kindly to this,
and I think academics have a lot of sunk costs going on into their careers,
and you don't have a lot of great options.
If you bail from the academy,
you've spent decades getting where you are.
It had to be a passion to get there.
So it's like,
I want to say it there.
No,
I share it with you.
By the way,
one of the first people who talked to me in whispers after we came public was a
friend of mine with multiple PhDs,
big time academic guy.
And he came up and he was so excited.
Now he's even talking low even though we were alone.
And um,
yeah,
it was like,
you know,
whispering almost to me literally,
even though we were just the two of us.
And he said,
you know,
I am so thrilled to let you do it.
It's needed to happen,
blah,
blah.
The academy needs to change in these reform.
Please don't tell anybody I said this and my reaction,
and I'm a very,
very calm patient person.
For people who don't know me,
I,
I don't think I get mad maybe once a year,
if that over anything.
And maybe I need to,
I don't know,
but different show different.
I became mad at him like immediately my reaction was you coward.
But then I thought about how much he's invested in.
So I think Pete's right.
Compassion is necessary for the silent professors,
but what we need also is for those who are courageous enough to open their
mouth,
but more people who say they look at the old communist thing where the communist
regime is falling,
but everybody's kind of going along with it and everybody knows if they're the
first person to step out that they're going to get shot or dragged off or
whatever and it's going to silence everybody else.
But if everybody at once in the town or the city or whatever all said,
you know,
communism's bullshit,
they couldn't do anything about it.
It's too,
are you guys then you're sort of saying both things at the same time.
I mean,
I get it like let's be compassionate towards people and I get it.
People have other considerations and careers and families and all those things
and I'm not denying any of that.
But you guys aren't superheroes.
I'm not as over here.
Just speak up and I'm incredibly
grateful for the people who have spoken up and has anyone not survived.
I mean,
I think this is the other thing that we have to push.
Has anyone that spoke up about these things that spoken up?
Yes.
People who have lost their jobs.
And,
and you know,
uh,
James Demora Google and um,
Lindsay Shepherd,
it looks already execute,
but no one's been executed.
If anything,
these people are all stronger at some level.
So yeah,
I agree with that actually.
Yeah.
So,
so that to me,
that's where we have to go with him.
I'm really incredibly grateful for the people who have spoken up and I'm telling
my email box has been flooded with letters of support students,
people that don't know people all over the world.
And I'm incredibly grateful for that.
And what we are seeing is more and more people are putting their names on this.
That's our big change.
We're seeing that in biology for example.
So that's what gives me hope for this whole thing.
And so I have only two colleagues who have publicly come out and said that they
have support me out of the whole university.
And you know,
the Portland State University vanguard published this crazy smear hit piece on
me with a huge nose as the film I'm fill in and they spelled his name wrong.
They said Hell had seven of these are 1110 with PhDs.
Couldn't even spell two of the three names correctly and they didn't.
It was anonymous.
The people who design side,
it was all,
it was students and faculty and Blah,
blah,
blah.
There's no color.
So brave.
If they had the truth on their side and they were so right and you were so evil,
well you could at least put your name.
I got,
yeah.
Well that's also the part of it is that at the James Damore event,
when it was just James Warren,
myself was hosted at points in university.
We emailed the women's studies department with James Shore and myself and we
said,
come on stage and let's,
let's have it.
It wasn't a debate.
A spirited conversation got to rejections and nothing else.
Two days later,
February 19th James,
Lindsay Hill blockers,
and myself,
the first thing I said at the James Damore event,
please women's,
anyone with a phd in cause you don't want to punch down,
right?
Anyone who is qualified as PhDs published in share,
please come up,
we'll give you a seat on stage,
you can talk right beside us and we'll have a spirit of conversation.
Nothing,
nothing.
And then at myth con,
later on,
the organizers try to find some,
they said they,
they told me they spent 80 hours trying to find a qualified person,
someone in the field of gender studies.
No one would go on with James,
Lindsey and clay Routledge in myself.
Is this the brilliance of what they've done?
And I mean that obviously slightly tongue in cheek,
which is you label everyone a racist than a Nazi and everything.
And then you say,
well,
these people don't deserve platforms.
So either they won't give you the platform in the first place or if they've
given you the platform.
Well,
they already have.
They're out,
which is,
I don't sit on platforms with Nazis.
So,
thus they've created this engine that,
uh,
that gives them the ultimate escape and gives you new opera,
no opportunity to defend your ideas to them.
And one crucial piece to that,
which is,
uh,
one of the differences between traditional religions,
Christianity in particular,
is that they,
they don't value discourse and dialogue.
It's just not part of their canon.
In fact,
if anything,
it's viewed as a full violence.
And so when you have folks who in not only they don't value it,
they're already winning the cultural war.
Right?
I know that might be a controversial statement,
but,
but certainly they're winning the cultural and the academy.
Nope,
we're making it.
I think we're making some gains,
but I think by and large gains,
and I think that can be metrics are like how many people are putting their names
when they come out on these letters or when they're speaking publicly about it.
But why would you have a conversation or a debate with someone if you know
you're already winning?
It's like the presidential debate.
You want to have more if you're losing in fewer if you're winning.
And so I think that's also operative.
So this is where it gets a bit deep if you want.
Why does that happen?
Um,
I mean obviously you can look at it and just that it's this brilliant strategy
in a sense.
But um,
their literature,
again,
like I said earlier,
they're terrified of complicity,
right?
They're going to be complicit in something.
So sharing the stage with somebody with a views equals complicity and also
giving them a platform.
But it's really difficult to understand that for,
for people outside of this kind of,
we call applied postmodern,
it changed in the 90s it's not the same as Foucault and Derrida and all this
nonsense deconstruction stuff.
It's a bit more focused.
It's really,
it's,
it's identity activism.
If you're outside of that view,
it's very difficult to understand how this all works.
They,
they,
why do they see something like conversation or dialogue is violence.
And the reason is that they see that everything is,
is,
has identity in and they see identity as an ideology,
ideology connected to identity bakes,
that ideology into whatever it produces.
So you and I are p three white guys sitting here and we're saying we should have
conversation which should have conversation.
And their answer is,
well of course you should.
You'd say you have conversation.
White people baked up.
The idea of having a conversation to get to idea so that they can maintain their
power.
So it's got this huge nasty conspiracy theory element that comes down to the
very roots of what we would call applied postmodernism,
which is the privilege and power exists to perpetuate and legitimize themselves.
If you don't understand that that's how they view the world.
It looks like they're playing this very dirty game,
but they actually really think that this is something that we did.
It's different.
By the way from socal is socal wrote the pastiche.
We started with these hoaxes.
The first six papers we wrote,
the ones that just died,
cause if you remember where he said 20 and then we talked about 14 of them,
seven accepted,
seven more in play.
We started with hoaxes and we couldn't get hoaxes in.
We couldn't replicate socal cause.
And we think the reason is either,
it could be our skill,
but it could also be that something changed and we think that something
fundamentally changed in the late eighties and early nineties and under Kimberly
Crenshaw's critical race theory and intersectionality,
uh,
she literally says that we need to apply postmodernism and mapping the margins.
That's the paper that the first mention of that section then yes,
that is the birthplace of intersectionality.
And she says that we can't achieve things if all we do is deconstruct.
So we need to admit that some things are real identities,
real and oppression based on identity are real.
And we need to use postmodern methods,
apply postmodern or methods of deconstruction to achieve things through those
assumptions.
So it's a big turn.
So they literally see that privilege and power exist to maintain themselves,
legitimize themselves.
And so there's this whole kind of weird conspiracy theory element to it from
their perspective that Oh,
you want to use reason because reason was invented by Western values that want
to perpetuate themselves and dominate the world.
And you want to use science and evidence because same reason and you want to
have conversation for the same reason.
And then when you start tying,
it's incredible.
It's deep.
It's Pr.
Unbelievably profound.
It's like the very thing that got you into the,
into the cognitive sinkhole in the first place.
The thing that can emancipate you from that.
You deny access just like Boko Haram,
western education forbidden,
right?
The one thing that these folks need is western education,
So the very thing that caused the problem in the first place,
they avoid,
they won't take because it will liberate them from the thing that causes the
problem.
Yeah.
So that's what we set out to do though,
is to understand when our hoax has failed,
we set out to understand them on their own terms.
They call this being an outsider within.
Um,
and there was actually a huge,
like in,
in lesbian research early on and lesbian social researchers,
cause you know,
you go into female oriented spaces or whatever and they don't quite fit.
So they are an outsider,
but they're inside and then they document it.
And that was one of their kind of methodologies,
a approach.
So we became that outsiders within their thing.
And we wanted to actually understand the way that they think.
And so now we sit in this odd position where,
you know,
I have one foot in applied postmodern,
uh,
theology,
if you will,
and I have one foot in reality and I,
I can now see the world both ways.
And,
uh,
that's kind of like the thing that sets us apart from socal.
It's a thing that we have to offer that's very different because we understand
where they're coming from,
why they're coming from that place and how their logic and their approaches
broken or damaging or unethical or whatever it happens to be in that,
in that case.
So you mentioned sort of high level ways we can break them out as,
I mean,
one,
one simple.
I've had it,
a couple of simple ones as I've talked to kids at schools.
One is,
you know,
you'll say to the,
they'll say that they're for Islam and they're for gay people.
And then you'll say,
well,
um,
can any gay person,
is there any gate ma,
is there a mosque in America or anywhere in the West for that matter or anywhere
in east or anywhere that will,
uh,
have gay marriage?
And the answer is no.
There,
there might maybe be one discredited one somewhere apparently.
But so it's like,
how can we be for both of these things?
This,
this actually doesn't make sense.
And that sort of little bomb in their brain does set off something I find,
you know,
but like,
so you need a little tricks like that.
So the best thing,
which then they'll tell you you're an Islamophobe anyway or something.
But
I've found that actually asking people how the dog park paper,
the dog humping paper got honored and then explain what the paper says.
How did this paper get honored as exemplary scholarship and feminist geography?
I watched kind of,
it's like the eyes on focus and come back.
Yes,
I've seen it happen.
You need them to understand a certain amount of what you've done.
One about like,
wait a minute,
I'm freezing them and for gays,
but if no gay can get married at a mosque,
well now it seems like something sort of more obvious,
something like that.
One of the things I just wrote about this last year,
I'm skeptic magazine,
one of the things that I've learned from over a quarter century of critical
thinking is instead of asking people,
what is your evidence for that?
Which is a totally reasonable question,
I switched to what's called a disability question or discolor information
question.
I front load this and all of my,
my conversations now,
and it's basically a simple question,
how could that belief be false?
So someone tells you something and you say,
well,
how could,
how?
I'm not saying you are wrong about that.
Just like how could that be false?
Even asking that question opens up spaces,
you know,
enables people to process things and in a way in which they,
they ordinarily wouldn't.
It's an incredibly effective question.
Yeah.
So what tangible evidence is there that,
that this thing is starting to succeed?
Beyond that?
You know,
there was some cover given by some,
some big names.
There were some good press.
Not all the press was good.
Plenty of,
plenty of places.
When after you guys do,
I mean is there more credible evidence then?
What did they go after though?
They went after our motivation.
Yeah,
right.
It was a lot about your motivations in particular Mr. Controversy,
formulate your beliefs in the base of evidence.
Huge controversy.
Uh,
so what the question is,
what can be done well?
Well is there tangible evidence?
Yeah.
First of all we've had probably 10 to one support to distraction.
So people writing these negative pieces.
Yeah,
they're out there.
But I think it's 10 to one support.
And I keep hearing,
I know it's mostly whispered,
but PSP said some people are starting to put their names to it.
A lot of people did in his support after Portland state.
Um,
I'm hearing a lot of people say things like,
you got them and they know you've got them right.
You've got them and they know you've got them.
That's it.
That's powerful.
These are people in humanities departments that are telling,
of course,
I can't say who they are,
but they're saying they know you've got them.
And then the way we expected,
you know the tornado to come after us and then there was no tornado,
it was just kind of this rolling over thing and eventually it's nasty hip piece
in pizza,
student newspapers.
Right.
And that's my point is that people survive the Munster.
And I want people to understand that
that is,
it's so many people and now people are starting to put that the toe out or stick
their head out a little bit.
They're writing things or putting their name on it when speaking
up in their classes.
I get emails all the time,
Hey,
you know,
you emboldened me to speak off of my class.
And like I mentioned some of these papers,
I've mentioned this.
So we see a ground swell of people willing to question and challenge the names.
A huge thing when people come out.
I now have all these organizations that have endorsed me against,
you know,
the possible termination from my offenses.
So let's just jump there for just a sec because this is not as if it hasn't had
a professional costs for you guys.
Uh,
but for you in particular,
and I know you don't want to play the victim,
but can you just explain what the hell is going on over at Portland state right
now?
So,
um,
they charged me,
there are two charges.
One is not going to the RB human subjects and they considered the researchers,
humans,
they,
excuse me,
the journal editors,
human subjects and I was found guilty on that and it's escalated to wait.
Can you explain that a little bit further?
So there are these things called Arby's and anytime you experiment on people,
it originally from Tuskegee and medical experiments,
you need to get permission from this board and tell them exactly what you're
going to do so that they know that the,
the subjects upon whom you're doing whatever in,
in,
um,
intervention are going to be fine.
So I was found guilty of not going to that.
Those are public documents that can be revealed when I received it.
And then that that has escalated to the provost and the president of the
university and they can make a decision about punishments.
I was also told that I have to take a training and there's,
I can't do any,
my,
I can't be a primary researcher,
a researcher on it and anything until this has been,
um,
adjudicated.
Then it's,
then it's the other charges,
fabrication of data.
These are very serious turn the foundation of data in particular.
And the idea behind that is that you don't want the research stream to be
contaminated,
right?
So we can't have people putting,
making stuff up,
basically publishing it.
And then what,
why people do that,
the motivation is to advance their own careers,
to get grants to publish and get tenure or what have you.
Even though that's obviously not what you guys were doing,
you weren't falsifying data does sell off a paper that was gonna make you look
like a rock star to get another position.
You were actually trying to help the institutions that we're trying.
There's a,
we can talk about the motivations,
but trust has been eroded in our public institutions.
Trust has been enrolled in the academy and it's a huge problem.
And,
but we can talk about that.
So that invest investigation is ongoing.
And so again,
my union rep informed me and my lawyers that the punishment for that can be
termination.
So I'm,
I'm now kind of caught in limbo and I honestly do not know what's going to
happen.
Are you in any hot water beyond?
No,
I'm not in any,
I,
I'm out of the academy,
so I don't have a,
I have no institutional review board over me and I have,
I have nobody coming down on me.
I mean,
I did basically have to stop working my job for almost two years to do this.
So I'm semi borderline unemployed and it's kind of,
you know,
I don't think I'm getting into academia again.
Well,
if I wanted to try to get into that,
so I'm not in the next couple of killer hot water.
But that's sort of the huge irony of this,
right?
So pizza and hot water.
But why?
Because he's an incident in an,
I'm free to do this and then there's nobody who can come down on me.
But P is under the,
you know,
possibly losing his job and all of this,
professional misconduct stuff.
It seems like it has technicality written all over it.
It's like,
Oh,
you happen to be the in the wrong position.
Now I understand that these boards are important and what they do and then
investigation needs to be be had.
But at the same time it does have technicality written all over it.
There's,
there's some weird,
how is it that they're,
this is ethical if I do it,
but unethical if he does it by,
by virtue of the fact that he has an academic position that should credential
him higher than that.
I'm credentialed,
but it doesn't,
it doesn't seem to really make any sense.
So for me,
I've not really had any hot water.
I also live in the south east,
which helps quite a bit because a,
as I was walking around,
you know,
I'm here in southern California,
so I'm walking around in Hollywood.
Last night we'd go out and somebody who's like,
that guy's one of us and I was like,
everybody where on from was one of us.
What are you talking about?
I don't understand.
Um,
everybody agrees with me about,
I mean they don't agree with my politics necessarily.
I've do firmly plant myself on the left,
but at the same time I,
they certainly agree with me about gender studies.
They certainly agree with.
They even go further than I would go.
I think gender studies is important.
For example,
I think we should be studying gender in a,
in a multidisciplinary way.
I just think it should have to follow,
you know,
the lines of evidence that should have to admit when it's wrong.
Right?
Yeah.
It's happening though.
Race is a huge issue.
Look how explosive it is.
For example,
for the last several years it's been like the most explosive social topic.
How are you going to do it if you're not doing it rigorously?
Do you think though it's possible that that race,
let's say is the most explosive topic because of what they have created,
what they have sewn.
When you,
when you increase people's awareness of race or gender or identity,
you make it touchier.
You make it a bigger deal.
You make people look for reasons to dig into it and you do explode the issue,
right?
Yeah.
Because if everything being equal,
if you asked me,
I mean,
I've been saying this a little bit more and I don't get any great joy in saying
it,
but if you asked me where the real racism is coming from right now,
it's coming from them.
It's again,
it's,
I mean,
I say this all the time and everyone knows there's,
yes.
Are there a couple of KKK members?
Are there a couple,
a white supremacist?
Yes.
Do they have any institutional power?
No.
Does anyone with any academic power or anything think that they're good?
No,
but,
but this thing has power behind it.
So that's why I fear it much more and the way that it's used.
Racism,
racism in conservative circles coming from the southeast and having lived there
for almost 40 years,
uh,
has definitely changed dramatically in my life.
Um,
the attitudes are very,
very different.
I honestly,
it's,
it's a whole separate show or whatever because the south has a complicated
relationship with race and racism and it's not simple and there's a lot of
issues,
but there are also a lot of improvements.
Uh,
but certainly you don't see the kind of institutional racism that we used to.
There's some weird stuff around and whether that touches into it or not because
it's also got seriously legitimate things that need to be heard and discussed
that the left progressive left,
cause I don't want to lump the whole left into the progressive left refuses to
have those conversations.
Honestly,
you know,
when you dump 1.8 million people into a culture,
all of a sudden would have a totally different culture.
Things happen when they,
you know,
there's,
there's real issues around immigration and I really wish we could have grown up
conversations about it instead of,
oh,
it's 100% open borders versus 100% you know,
build a wall or whatever the hell it is.
And so I wish we could have a real conversation there.
And part of the reason we can't is because one side is like it's racist to have
the conversation.
So I do actually generally agree with you that the crusade to make race more
salient,
which is almost directly out of critical race theory and the crusade to make
gender identity more salient,
which was almost straight out of gender theory.
We can go on dry dental,
the sexuality theory,
Fat Studies,
while we write down the list of every identity category.
You can imagine the intersectional Matrix of dominance that increases.
Everybody's touching us,
everybody's willingness to be offended and everybody's,
everybody who can manipulate their offense to their own advantage,
their ability and willingness maybe to take that advantage where,
yeah,
where it's
there.
All right.
Well that's why I believe it is the most dangerous set of ideas out there.
I believe that this set of ideas,
the way you just laid it out,
is far more dangerous than anything I'm seeing out of what Trump's saying.
And again,
someone that didn't even vote for Trump,
I would say that that is what is going to turn neighbor against neighbor.
You will look at your neighbor and judge them by the color of their skin and
what they should get for that.
Or because they're overweight or because they're a woman or because they're gay.
I mean,
that is what it,
it,
it's the,
it's the complete ripping of the fabric of everything that America is.
Yeah.
I have four.
The idea after,
I mean,
I certainly agree with that.
I have to pause on the Trump thing.
I,
yeah,
me too.
I've been on a Trump die.
I,
I just,
I so can't stand,
we almost did an hour without saying Trump.
Um,
yeah.
And you know what?
I don't mean to make it either or,
but this vision,
no question about it.
That this is a toxin and it's contagious and it's destroying our societies.
And again,
it's coming from one place and if people want to know why should they care about
a bought a bunch of Kooky academics,
it's because this stuff spills out into the real world and it spills out
consistently and we've now trained an entire generation of people both to be
brittle when they hear something to be offended like that.
If you have a belief that's an evidenced or if you're a intensely ideological
person,
then you have to do something to make up the slack when someone contradicts you,
when you're faced with an alternative and idea,
you can lie,
you can be offended,
we can walk away,
you can scream at people and call them a racist,
but you can't engage their ideas.
And now we've taught in an empty,
deeply concerned about this because we've taught an entire generation of kids to
to not do that.
What we should be doing is to not teach them how to suspend their judgments,
but to make better,
more
discerning judgments particularly is that spills into the moral sphere.
So how worried are you then,
um,
when this really seeps into the political system really does seem to me that
that's the horizon horizon right now.
If you look where all the energy is,
it's behind the set of young democratic socialists perfectly believe all of
this.
So that's why I'm,
that's why I think it's perfect.
I personally feel like Trump has borderline and unmitigated disaster now we've
done really well or institutions have been strong.
So I get worried about anybody who wants to tear down,
insert institutions,
given that they are a check or if he's a,
if he's an out of control executive,
that the institutional thing itself is what controls the out of control
executive.
That's the point of eliminating executive power is at the institution is broader
and you don't put it all in a tyrant or whatever.
If that comes along,
I don't know that he's a tyrant,
he's whatever.
But if I think,
let's say that I think,
and it's not perfectly true that he's the the most dangerous thing that's
happening in the world right now.
I actually,
and this is you want your controversy to see if I can talk Pete for ones.
Come on,
give me some money.
I think Trump is a result of the regressive left.
I think that he got elected because he stood up and he would,
you know all these,
these skulls for years and years and years.
You can't say that.
You can't think that.
You can't say that in Trump would just say it and so who?
Who's watching this?
You have this entire group of people who are sick.
I live in the south.
I talked to him all the time.
I know these people,
these are good,
decent people there.
No,
most of the time,
no fan of Trump in general.
They don't like what he's doing politically and yet they're like,
he doesn't care that those people said you can't say that.
He said it anyway he does.
You know you can't say such and such about this group.
Trump says it.
They think,
wow,
here's this kind of like Avatar of me being able to,
you know,
somebody else who can take the fall for it.
Take the heat for it.
Because if I say it,
I'm going to get blasted.
He says that he doesn't get in trouble.
That appealed to a lot of people and then you have an election that was a very
narrow margin.
You don't need a lot of people to have flipped a margin.
So I think the reason we got Trump was very significantly to do with the fact
that this stuff,
especially in 2015 decided to blow up to like the only thing you can talk about,
check your privilege,
everything and I'm afraid we're going to get it again.
And the reason I'm afraid especially is maybe you do,
maybe you don't know this,
I just recently found out that they're going to let trans athletes compete in
the Summer Games in 2020 right before the election.
I actually haven't heard that.
Yeah.
So they're going to let the Trans Athletes Compete as women in the,
in the 2020 games.
And that's going to happen literally a couple months before the next election.
The trans bathroom thing was a giant wedge issue.
Who drummed it up as a wedge issue?
I don't know.
But that's a whole,
like that's a fracture point in society right now.
And it is one because of the gender theory doesn't play out to where anybody can
understand what's going on and it feels like they're being told how they have to
think on issues.
And so then you finally have somebody who comes along and you see something
that's outrageous,
whether it's the bathrooms,
if when you start having like a trans wrestler that like slam some woman
right when you were seeing there's going to be horrible for overseas,
which like the MMA fighter and stuff that's just like,
and broke her jaw and it's just horrifying.
There's something off here and everybody can see it.
So I really think that these,
again,
these gender issues,
race issues,
these stupid culture war issues are going to possibly prove decisive.
So anybody who's,
who's out there that thinks that Trump is an unmitigated disaster has to pay
attention to the fact of how the audience that votes for him thinks about
this social justice crap and what it's doing for them.
So I mentioned this when I had Peterson in Shapiro on,
but in a weird way is this where let's say three guys,
I can't consider myself part of the left anymore,
but I know you do and I think you do,
but I still consider myself a liberal,
but that's okay,
fine.
Sure.
But is this where we should all be looking in the mirror and going,
man,
this is actually the failure of the liberals that when when this monster was
reconstituting itself in the name of progressivism,
that all the liberals just kind of jumped on board and knew something was kind
of off like where are the liberals?
The liberals were,
I mean I get it.
We can name 20 people.
Okay,
great.
Yeah,
I'm not a big fan of blame at this point.
I just want to fix all it'd be to mean if we want to fix it,
we have to figure out where our fault points where right.
That well if we want to fix it,
we have to say what's the best step forward.
And to your comment that you just made,
I don't think that the solution to this is to elect people to office who are
steeped in identity based politics.
I think that's completely agree with that.
That's a reaction to,
this is what I see.
A two.
Yeah.
Nick escalating series of reactions as well,
how it's happened.
And what was that recent study?
It was,
I think they wrote about it and the Atlantic and there was the eight,
seven political tribes,
right?
8% our social justice people,
some comparable percent are in two factions are far right.
That's right.
People.
And then you have this gigantic swath in the middle who are in the keyword was
politically exhausted.
So where are the liberals?
They're putting their head down and they're being quiet because those lunatic
fringes are,
whether it's classical liberals center or right,
or even dipping into the left because it works that way,
whether it's left liberals,
but you know,
true liberals are,
are,
are the people who need to rise up and say,
hey look,
no,
our society is a liberal society.
We're gonna,
we're gonna make sure it stays that way.
In the rest,
it's politics.
You know how we're going to sort out these issues as politics,
but we have to get to a place where we can have politics again,
where these lunatic fringes don't want to have it.
But I had this idea a couple of years ago that what we're seeing is,
and I think this is what's triggered the problem,
and liberals are just sick of getting yelled at and they're tired and it's
exhausting.
It's constant fighting.
It's constant war.
Most people don't want to fight.
But you have these two sides and each one is able to convince the people closer
to it that the other side's the next essential threat.
So every time my wedge issue comes up,
every person that sees themselves on the left sides with whatever that furthest
faction is,
when it comes down to it's gotta be this,
or it's gotta be that because they're so afraid that if the Conservatives get
power,
you know,
gays aren't gonna be able to get married,
they're going to overturn roe versus Wade did.
Everybody's going to have a coat hanger abortions or something.
The next thing you know,
climate change is going to ruin the planet.
They've in the people on the conservative side,
see the same thing.
If the Liberals get power,
if those Democrats get power,
we're going to have open borders.
Muslims are going to be flooding in rapists from Mexico.
It's going to be this whole thing and they freak out and it's an excess.
They feel existential threat if the other side gets power.
And what that's done has been this ratcheting up of tension.
So the people in the middle get exhausted and they only make a choice when they
feel forced to make a choice.
And then they don't choose to be with that extremist group,
right?
They trues not to be with those and they take,
take,
uh,
they take a very broad stroke side.
What's the solution to this?
Shut up.
Extremists were going down the middle now,
right?
So somebody comes out with an extremist thing and it's that same thing I said
earlier,
I know what that is.
No,
we're not doing that.
I think one of the most important things,
and this is in our forthcoming book about how to have impossible conversations.
Peter and I just finished,
one of the most important things is to learn to disavow the extremists on your
side,
so if you see yourself on the left,
say,
you know those guys,
they don't represent me way off to the left.
I think I'm on the left,
but I distinguished myself from them and learn how to articulate that and then
the left can clean up inside.
You can get that main body of people on the left speaking out saying those the
80% don't represent us.
Here's what we really believe,
and on the right,
the same thing.
If you're on the right,
you say,
you know what,
fine,
I'm on the right.
Good.
Those dudes way over there,
these guys that want to dissolve the government and drown in the bathtub used to
be the saying,
right?
There's shrink it to the size.
You can drown in about them.
They don't represent me.
Okay.
That goes too far.
We need a society that functions that goes too far.
I have conservative values.
I have this,
I have that.
But that goes too far.
And if you then the right can start cleaning itself up because right now if the
left tries to insist the right cleanup,
the right can't hear it
because it's an existential polarizations.
Interesting to me because I agree with you obviously on the left part that the
left knee,
the liberals need to do that.
But to me the right basically is doing that.
They're fighting constantly about these things because you've got healthy
branches of Trump people and never Trumpers.
And Libertarians.
There's,
there's actually some debate versus one side has the religious and the x
community.
I feel like that has,
has come to be the case over the past maybe four or five years.
I feel like there is,
there has been a change to more openness and more dialogue on the right and I
think it's a necessary corrective to what they're seeing from the far left.
I don't think that was the case,
uh,
10 years ago.
Um,
I feel like at the time of the right was locked down to the left was kind of
having these squabbles and then it's kind of switched which side is
recalcitrant.
And I think it'll probably switch again then
eventually.
Oh,
I'm curious since both of you guys are outspoken,
atheist,
are,
is part of your worry about all of this that it seems that this set of the
postmodern thing is very anti religious in its own way.
Now I know you're okay with the anti religion part,
but because they've used this set of ideas as their own religion,
does that,
you know in any way,
do you see that as a weakness of atheism?
You know what I mean?
Like they've by,
by removing all religion altogether,
they had a void of belief.
So now they just picked this belief that may be the skeptic community or the
atheist community or something needed to do more to,
to provide some sort of groundwork
solution hypothesis.
Right.
And so my background for the last several years before I became a renegade
feminist
was a your Twitter bio.
It is.
That is your Twitter bio?
Yeah.
Renegade gender scholar or something happened in their [inaudible] hypothesis is
important.
And I think that,
you know,
next time we have a car tissue with Peterson or yeah we should talk to him about
this is this is I think one of the things that people misunderstand so well
that's why I love you.
So there's three
pillars to why people at a psychosocial level,
they call it,
why they believe or why they ascribed to religions,
what,
what function do they play sociologically and psychologically.
One is for a feeling of,
of meaning,
making purpose,
morality,
Cetera and understanding the world.
And that is kind of,
I think what the substitution hypothesis often touches upon.
Like they had this path to find meaning.
Then it went away.
God was killed by the postmodern deconstruction.
Now they don't have a meaning structure.
Then they look also for community.
How,
how communities are formed,
how they're organized,
how you,
how you find standing within your community.
That also got deconstructed.
Um,
so there's an aspect to both of those that people are trying to fill in.
I don't think that that explains extremism though.
So the work that I've done looking into the psychology of extra of extremism is
the extremism isn't,
you don't go extreme because you're looking for meaning because you have people
who are moderate religious people all over the world who are very,
very devout,
who aren't extremists.
And you don't get extreme necessarily just a form of community.
You can,
those are calls where you start to find extremism is where people,
the third dimension that people go to religion for is to have a sense of control
in life.
And I feel like we're in a state probably because of many technological advances
happening so rapidly with the Internet blooming and everything is so different
now than it was when I was a kid.
You know,
Nintendo was the thing.
And now that we've got this,
you know,
huge internet and indeed global connectedness,
I can text people in Australia,
I could get my phone right now and do it and it immediately.
So we've got this whole different world now and I think what's happened is
people are feeling a loss of control now.
Part of that's going to come because there's been this massive deconstruction of
institutions alongside it.
Um,
but I feel like the extremism that you see comes less from a meaning making
place and more from a feeling out of control place.
Because when you feel out of control,
you try to lock things down.
And so I think the,
actually,
if you want to look at like a big political kind of solution to ratchet things
down is it's,
it's very important right now that we start trying to look at things that will
actually succeed and giving people a greater sense that society is under control
and a culture we're sure as hell isn't that.
And then the,
you know,
being politically panicked,
whether it's the Obama's in office and he's going to ruin the universe from the
conservative side or Trump's in office,
he's going to ruin the universe from the liberal side.
Whatever it is,
that panic isn't a feeling of control.
It's a feeling of being out of control.
And that's why these issues carry existential concern for people and they,
they're go so extreme.
So I think it's,
I think that both the community and the meaning making structures are relevant,
but to combined,
they probably explain less than 20% of what we're seeing with these kinds of
postmodern religions or whatever.
And most of it,
at least in their extremist forums where they matter like hipsters or a
postmodern religion and who cares?
Who Cares?
But where it gets troublesome as where you have people who feel like they're out
of control and if they don't exert authoritarian control,
everything's going to be terrible.
And so I think that it's more of a more an access of control than an access of
meaning making.
Although it is more difficult,
uh,
to find meaning in a world where you don't just have this grand sweeping
narrative of whether it's religion,
whether it's nationalism,
whether it's whatever it is,
um,
western values as a big one.
Right?
So I think,
you know,
Bret Weinstein I saw was tweeting about this the other day.
I think there's a,
there's a thing where we all had this shared narrative of what it means to be
American or the shared narrative,
what it means to be spreading democracy abroad or whatever the thing was.
You know,
this western thing and that even if you are religious or not religious,
you could lock into that.
And there was this kind of shared meaning.
So that's the one I would be thinking is the most scary.
That we're deconstructing the fact that these people are so focused on race,
are so focused on gender,
et Cetera is one thing.
But the fact that they're so focused on being anti Western centric,
everything that the west,
it is imbued with dominance and colonialism and power and it's always trying to
maintain itself.
So that's the thing we need to deconstruct most.
That's the scariest idea.
Yeah.
All right.
P bring us home on a hopeful note that we can not only turn the tide,
but we can get enough people to be brave enough and the emails will come
anonymously and that we can restore some,
some sanity or James billionaire fact.
Not only,
not only can we do this,
but we are doing it.
People are starting to respectfully speak on in their classes.
People are starting to sign their names to two petitions and letters of support
and people are starting to genuinely attempt to be honest brokers of
conversation after it,
a minimum of five years of feeling that they couldn't speak openly or they
couldn't speak freely.
So there's no question at all that the tide is turning and that something has
changed in the air.
I think that the next steps forward are that not only do we continue to question
within the class,
within the academic environment,
but we also do so in a way that's civil and polite and respectful.
We never want to lose that in our society and we've seen the consequences of
that already.
So reason has been slapped around and people feel rightly so that they haven't
been able to to speak out and in a way that accords with their conscience and
the step to get back to those values I think is to continue to attempt to be
civil and have an honest conversation with somebody.
And if,
if you're met with rage or anger,
the response is not to meet someone that rage or anger.
I'll keep doing it.
If you guys keep doing it fair,
we'll keep doing it.
Quintin.
Alright,
follow these guys on Twitter.
It's at conceptual James and at Peter Boghossian and we'll link to where you
want me to link to one of the videos.
Fortunately,
Mike name his youtube channel as the place to go if you want to see what we're
up to,
what we've been up to,
what we've done,
what he's putting out.
It's all on the same theme.
He's his youtube channels,
our hub,
and great,
don't miss it.
We're going to have a link to that right down below.